[Music]
how about a little bit of Hope here
America's inaugural youth poet laureate
is offering some inspiration for all of
us we asked Amanda Gorman to use her
talents to remind us that there is hope
out there in a performance before our
cameras at the Los Angeles Central
Public Library
Gorman turned to her impressive voice to
give us comfort and courage to this
nation and at a time when we need both
[Music]
I thought I'd awake into a world in
mourning heavy clouds crowding a society
storming but there's something different
on this golden morning something magical
and the Sun lights wide and warming I
see a dad with a stroller taking a jog
across the street a bright-eyed girl
chases her dog a grandma on a porch
fingers her rosaries she grins as a
young neighbor brings her groceries well
we might feel small separates and all
alone or people have never been more
closely tethered the question isn't if
we will whether this unknown but how we
will weather this unknown together so on
this meaningful morn we mourn in jury
men like lights we can't be broken even
when we bend
[Music]
as one we will defeat both despair and
disease we stand with healthcare heroes
and all employees with families
libraries schools waiters artists
businesses restaurants and hospitals hit
hardest we ignite not in the lights but
in lack thereof for it is and loss that
we truly learn to love in this chaos we
will discover clarity and suffering we
must find solidarity
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
or it's or grief that gives us our
gratitude shows us how to find hope if
we ever lose it so ensure this ache was
injured in vain do not ignore the pain
give it purpose use it
[Music]
[Applause]
we'd children's books dance alone to DJ
music know that this distance will make
our hearts grow fonder from a wave of
woes or world will emerge stronger
[Music]
will deserve how the burdens braved by
humankind are also the moments that make
us humans kind let every dawn find us
courageous but closer heating the lights
before the fights is over when this eyes
will smile sweetly finally seeing in
testing times we became the best of
beings Wow beautiful girl beautiful
words beautiful spirit I have a terrible
terrible girl crush on this on this
young woman I think she's knockout and
shout out to Kyra Cleveland Chris bender
who put that piece together we always
say guys you know this Tony it's hard to
do with no track and have it make sense
that was knockout